c'est le voisinage qui a donné l'alerté
vers 18h40 ne la fumée puis rapidement
des flammes de plusieurs mètres
s'élèvent d'un des restaurants du marché
à cette heure heureusement la halle est
déjà fermée les pompiers dépêchés sur
les lieux
parviennent à empêcher la propagation de
l'incendié mais au matin c'est la
désolation pour de restaurateurs qui ont
tout perdu et un troisième dans le box
est fortement endommagé par la fumée et
l'eau les causes du sinistre
seront à confirmer par les experts les
pompiers nous ont donné déjà des
premières la première conclusion
première conclusion c'est bien une
défaillance électrique alors le réseau a
bien été déjà vérifié par la ville de
fort-de-france savez lorsqu'on met à
disposition le box il ya quand même une
vérification qui est fait pour que bien
faire en sorte que le réseau puisse se
tenir par rapport à l'activité qui
exerçait à l'intérieur du box
ça peut être un matériel qui était
défectueux
qui a brûlé qui a entraîné l'incendié ça
peut être ça mais je vous le dis pour
l'instant nous attendrons que les
experts nous écrivent leurs
préconisations ce matin aucun
restaurateurs ou employés n'acceptera de
témoigner devant nos caméras mais les
pertes pourront dépasser les 40 mille
euros et le temps des travaux après
expertise prendra sans doute des mois
mettant six personnes au chômage
technique
entre temps par sécurité le courant
n'est pas encore établie dans la halle
et les trois autres restaurants et bars
ni par le feu ne peuvent pas encore
ouvrir dans les boutiques de souvenirs
[Musique]
l'absence d'électricité pénalise
l'activité mais on se débrouille avec le
sourire
pour l'instant la ville de fort de
france attend les vérifications des
techniciens pour renvoyer le courant
dans l'ensemble du marché sans risquer
de nouveaux dommages